wild Minds people who think about the
world in unique ways you like also think
about the world in unique ways you won't
like I started think about this years
ago when people were like Elon Musk is
kind of rude on Twitter and he's saying
the wrong things and he's not very
polite to people of course this is a guy
who at age 30 took on GM Ford and NASA
at the same time and succeeded like of
course he's not a well-balanced
individual of course he has these crazy
quirks the reason that people like and
admire Elon Musk is because he doesn't
think any of the rules apply to him and
he's willing to take these Bonkers bets
on new technologies and new engineering
and with that an unavoidable part are
these parts of the world where he thinks
about the world differently in negative
ways and he can be a j he has different
political views than people and you
cannot separate those two you cannot
have somebody who is a crazy out of boox
thinker in a positive way and also
dresses and speaks and looks and is
polite like an average citizen it does
not exist